we're doing the legends and we're doing
Viktor Korchnoi and I thought I'd do
something funny I've had a lot of funny
conversations with question over the
years yes um I'm not sure he was all
there but probably I wasn't either so so
I've heard pretty good conversations I'd
also play bridge with Viktor Korchnoi
and that was very funny also uh anyway
I've known Viktor forever and ever and
ever but I think he forgot meeting me
longer than I knew I met him so these
things happen about four years ago I was
supposed to play a match with Korchnoi
and it was all set and I was going to
show him who the boss was you know him
and instead he got he fell ill and he
couldn't play the match and my opponent
got 65 years younger ray Robson and I
showed him who the boss was too because
I think you already knew but maybe not
okay so Viktor Korchnoi I thought I'd do
a fun lecture I'll show a game that he
wanted every decade okay so first we
look at him from 1830 his guy now of
course he was born way before that but
he learned chess late okay
so Viktor was born a long time ago in a
gala
he's in his 80s now and he's not playing
as much as a used to or at all he's been
ill for quite a while but he's in good
spirits he's so poised I think for fun
but not in rated tournaments now this
game first game is from 1951 I'm going
to show games that you are in the 50s
60s 70s 80s 90s and 2000's 2010's he
didn't win so many games so on some but
you know the lecturers getting before
them okay first game is against Vladimir
Zak this was played in the Leningrad
Shigure memorial this game is so old the
name of the city has changed seven times
since and nobody knows what it is now I
think the shuffleboard Hall of Fame is
somehow in st. Petersburg now I don't
get it okay
I think it a lot of YouTube comments
that's not the read st. Petersburg
okay and your indolence is inefficacious
okay so Victoire no dog food tonight for
Victoire don't sue me Futurama play D
for what I like about coercion oi other
than his craziness which is really cool
okay and his terrible mean spirit which
is also very funny I like all that stuff
about him is he plays every opening with
both sides and he always plays to win no
drawings okay so he's white 9c3
ridiculous although I would play it yeah
this is actually the game Feingold
Shanklin u.s. championship 1-0 you hear
me talking Julien yeah okay Bishop f5
now this is the game priyadarshan
Feingold
0-1 okay yeah I think I put this [ __ ]
about five okay and cautiously play
Bishop g5 you don't have to do a lot of
opening theory especially in 1951 all
right c5 the most complicated and course
my likes when it's so complicated nobody
knows what's going on and there's a very
famous you know triage of you know a
triumvirate of results between three
players cautionary tall and poor dish
your three favorite players okay you've
actually heard of all three unlike most
people in the room okay including head
west all right course shouldn't always
be tall tall always be poor dish and
poorest always be course right okay now
tall like to mix it up and course noise
like grapes
okay let's mix it up most guys are like
no not tall
okay so c5 is the most aggressive
complicated move not good against
coronoid course Knight took d4 what's
the most complicated move white can make
anyone Julian efore now all the pieces
are hanging okay and that's good for
course join now it's also good for
course joy is white has two pieces
developed and black has one and whites
Bishop can move out especially Bishop b5
check and blacks Bishop can move and
whites get a castle before black and
course noise favorite what score should
eyes favorite kind of classes this did
stay up on quarter before the class even
though you didn't owe the classes about
course join terrible okay
what's best about it is coronoid loves
being a pawn up okay if this appointment
has meetin and it's his opponents move
he still wants to be a pawn up
that's how dedicated he is to being a
part up okay so black played Bishop to
g6 one of the issues with trading here
these pieces is Bishop b5 check is going
to be annoying and white has the two
bishops okay so instead Bishop g6 9 to
b5 attacking the pawn on d4 Knight c6
defending the pawn on d4 Knight f3 when
I said last time f6 now what rule does
this break Julian never play f6 and even
though I wasn't to be born for 18 more
years you think Zach would know that
rule yeah that would be better
anything's better than f6 the worst now
AB 6 weakens e6 and it weakens the
diagonal and courts like takes into
school picked him up at 3:30 on time
that's nice of him Victor's a good guy
okay so 9 takes d4 the most complicated
move ever hanging the bishop probably he
didn't see it then he might have seen it
okay and this is so complicated that I'm
confused now if the pawn was on f7 we
wouldn't worry about 96 now that's all
we're worried about 96 no okay
so White's sacrificing a piece but
blacks King is very bad
also white has a lot of pawns 9 takes 9
9 takes and now he didn't take the
bishop I would have taken the bishop but
that loses immediately I'm not saying I
wouldn't do it if you change the bishop
then white starts attacking with all of
his pieces
okay now Queen f3 check ok draw agreed
now Knight f6 the obvious move Queen b3
check and if there was a referee he'd
stopped the fight
gay and black isn't a lot of trouble
okay
so instead Jack played Bishop takes e4
okay complicated 96 attacking the Queen
and black saw it
darn he tried so instead of trading
Queens the computer says whites plus
four think he played a worse move Queen
CA Bishop c4 defending his Knight now
your opponent has a night on e six and
this is your pawn structure you know
you're going to like learn a new game or
something yeah yeah bug house yeah
terrible okay so this is the worst and I
know the worst trust me okay yeah I know
the worst pretty well okay so you took
the bishop now black is up a piece but
White has everything White has more
pawns White has more development blacks
King is going to get checkmated there's
forks and skewers and lions and tigers
and bears okay
and the Lions were good in the 50s so
this is his only chance okay since then
not so good no Bobby Lane fans in the
audience you yeah paper tiger yeah yeah
see as dumb as I look
seem to be or best testing indicates
okay nine takes g5 threatening
everything now those of you in the
audience
you see Knight takes Bishop which I'm
already surprised at but some of you
also see Bishop f7 checkmate with
advantage okay so white has a lot of
threats Queen f5 defending everything
and white resigned what a terrible
player course now is no that's not what
happened
Bishop e6 that's the meanest who have
you ever seen because we're threatening
me and the Queen okay and most of you
would have played Bishop f7 check which
is also good and then no because white
black sacrifices his Queen and black
gets three pieces for Queen and he's
still getting crushed but this should be
six is better now let's see who the best
defender in the house is I know it's Ken
West but who can play the only good move
black and that's what black played who
can defend everything except really
nothing that's okay I'll take a drink
while you guys are thinking
Julian incorrect correct
Riggs what's the best move rugby it now
most of you would play some crazy move
like me but he played a scene move
ridiculous yeah correct
yay now most of you would play queen g6
and then Bishop f7 check is annoying
because white wins all of blacks pieces
okay so black played g6 okay Bishop
takes Queen pawn takes Queen this should
takes Bishop now if you're good at
counting then they have the same number
of pieces and whites up a lot of pawns
this is really winning this is White's
I'm a lot of material and white has all
of his advantages this ship takes B 796
doubled H pawns black has good
development okay so they so now black
played the great move Julian incorrect
you did not make a move yeah blacks up
blacks losing a lot of material this is
weak this is weak this looks good for ye
black resigns with no development this
is the best time to resign because when
you reset the pieces you're half done
blacks got little to do why does a lot
of work to do okay so of course just
play man that he won this game okay in
1951 they didn't have ratings they just
like I'll play you know Zack was a good
player I heard of him so yeah so he was
reasonable player okay what's that yeah
okay now this is the Israeli Grandmaster
Libre Zama maybe he was Russian before
that 1960 because we did 1950 now it's
time for 1960 okay kid Ken West is
feeling very nostalgic right now wait
were you live in 1951
what they were thinking of you okay yeah
course I was like what would Ken West
you I'm not born yet never mind all
right
that's he was thinking too sorry he
wasn't thing at Arby's didn't happen yet
all right so of course should I play d4
X clam if you were paying attention you
weren't course so he's black this games
I wasn't paying attention either too too
much to drink
terrible okay II for C 5 he pled the
Sicilian what's the best Sicilian Ken
West okay first of all Julian's gonna
said the dragon then after he said he's
going to say Sicilian pizza
okay so course Tony plays the Sicilian
naturally it's a Sicilian pizza then
okay as Ken West can tell you Domino's
Pizza has changed its name to Domino's
you see how could you not know that all
right but they sponsored me I have to
mention the occasional okay so a six
this is the Consul Ian and I showed this
game before the class to make sure it
was well played I show it's a William
Shatner What did he say Ken I said what
did he say he said Khan come on man I
kind of give him the script he didn't
read it he edited it that was nice okay
so consilience Kip the opening because
course I put the greatest thing I ever
saw
it's the most boring whatever Joe so in
this position which can come from any
Sicilian first of all course I plays
King H a and then he plays King G a oh I
didn't play King G at this game play
later okay
so this is the position I wanted to get
to course should I played e5 the
craziest move I've ever seen and it's
really strong so course Tron was lucky
he probably missed everything and it all
worked out no no no all right so ii v is
my favorite move ever that's the one
move black can't play because white has
everything on it it's got his bishop and
it turns out they were playing bug house
he a lot of pieces to cover you v okay
II five anyway that's nothing to see
that that's a great move e5 okay so they
traded now I
was looking at without a computer never
a good idea because everything I see is
wrong and I was like why can't I take
this pawn I turned on the engine and
none of the moves were taking the pond
so I'm like give me some help here
come on so I figured out on my own after
using the computer after Bishop takes e5
I actually did figure out what black
does what is black what I just gave a
pawn away how could he but black is
winning here that's a pretty good pawn
sacrifice when you win in two moves
Julian incorrect no no you're more
incorrect yeah yeah I know I'm serious
black is winning in this position even
though he's a pawn down because he has a
trick who can find the winning trick I
know I couldn't but if I turn my engine
on I could find it pretty quick Julian
incorrect you're half correct when who
said nine h5 somebody good yeah
Queen c5 check Knight h5 put it in H as
in the famous game when I was in the
Hall of Fame like for six months come on
no spot spots key Fischer 9h five of the
bony clan yeah all right I hope your
song at home - all right 9 h5 attacking
the Queen and this is called removing
the defender the Queen is defending the
bishop on e5 and when the Queen moves
we're going to take the bishop out e5
luckily the knight is also stopping made
very lucky okay somehow question I saw
that now Queen takes losses a much
funnier way the Queen is defending the
bishop right so you play Bishop to d6
yeah the Queen is this the only safe
square
why don't I because I take your queen
yeah I saw what your trick was though
you can't trick me twice a day well four
times a day alright so this is the only
move I see and then check and then you
take the bishop and then you start
trash-talking okay so II five was a
really strong move and white played
Bishop III and now blacks better because
this Bishop as Lisa essentially would
say that's try to block you the bishop
is of little value right and black has a
better pawn structure White has an
isolated pawn and blacks bishops have
thousands of square Oh tens of thousands
of square okay don't count very well
okay so Bishop e6 and the game was
really boring after that until of course
like tore him apart
bit by bit okay now this got really
interesting when you're playing Korchnoi
try to trick him tactically because I
won't work okay so he played Bishop
takes b5 yeah exactly and he was hoping
after pawn takes Knight takes he could
fork the Queen and rook okay then maybe
black White's okay maybe not
instead course and I played queen b7
attacking everything when you sacrifice
a piece your opponent doesn't have to
take it now this is attacked a million
times and this is attacked a billion
times
this is attacked a trillion times okay
and here white fell apart once upon a
time he was falling in love and now he's
only falling apart yeah you agree okay
yeah was he being sarcastic he doesn't
know all right
so white played before
exactly and who would like to move b4
kokumo very good you're paying attention
we may who's Kokomo we ain't with him
yesterday yeah
ah he's like oh yeah alright yeah yeah
he read my book
yeah very good
so you didn't read his lines the guy's a
genius okay now notice that white just
attacked the knight and blacks attacking
the bishop confusion ensued except black
just took this pawn and all of whites
pieces are hanging that was unfortunate
now the rook has attacked bishops
attacked and white has nothing and the
game ends in a funny way because after
Knight takes rook takes you would expect
Y could play the trickiest move ever
Bishop takes a6 confusion and as Julian
pointed out after we trade these pieces
Queen takes rook mate is a good move
yeah um what's that anyone what mate on
the other hand if you don't play Bishop
takes a six that's unfortunate
what's that
ah Queen c5 here yeah that yeah then I
go here I guess I didn't i didn't see
queen c5 so i can't refute it yeah but
when I play queen's eggs trick i have
the same mate that was lucky
yeah yeah so what White's unlucky
because he's falling apart yeah okay so
here what do you think white did that's
right very good always preaching
resigned correctly so now White's losing
his Bishop because the Queen's attacked
and the bishop is attacked Bishop takes
be fight didn't work he tried and he
failed miserably the lesson is never try
okay now correlates white and it's 1970
are you surprised
no now can't Wesley 1970 that sounds
better
yeah Ken Wesley 1970 yes terrible Ken
was that your favorite year 1970 yeah
what year was I born 80s what's wrong
with you hey come on
he's the worst 69 dude come on 9 6 69 or
if you're in Europe 6-9 6-9 if you're in
Europe ok G yeah G 3 X clam core should
I played everything ok now they
transposed into a tar ash Queens gambit
declined not sure that happened this
could come from Atari s Queens gambit
declined this is like the main line they
transposed gay Bishop e6 terrible Bishop
e6 Bishop c5 illegal you mean why should
play Bishop g5
yeah but Knight Bishop e6 is terrible ok
horrible
that's the worst move ever now I'm
kidding Pawar was actually a child
prodigy but you never heard of him but
still okay Bishop e6 nom yum-yum-yum-yum
I took back 984 baby he won't see it
oh he's on ok and now black played b5
what would not come worse
maybe he would say frankly terrible b5
his bed it weakens everything the
night's not protected the diagonal is
open and now b5 is hanging a really bad
move okay and the players play chess
that was a good idea playing chess is
good
okay moving the Queen out of the way
moving the Queen out of the way I like
because the rook is on the file was a
queen good for white yeah II for
Korchnoi
the most aggressive move okay now black
didn't play this that would be my last
class the beginner class right rook
takes Queen so he played d4 92 white has
so many pieces of tagging d4 I can't
count that high
what do you think Martin how many what
what do you say what yeah what so
White's threatening this pawn with
everything he's got everything he's got
on it
he did play d3 very good alright now
here now we got two guys attacking it
and nobody defending it that's what he
was thinking haha okay did Knight takes
e4 Knight takes c6 and now the greatest
tactical sequence since all of Julian's
blitz games now there was a capture
every move
which really confused me but not
cautionary and not my engine my image is
like no problem it's takes Knight d4 now
everything black has is attacked his
knight on e4 is queen is d3 pawn he
tried Queen d5 Queen d3 that Knight
doesn't look too safe 9c 5 now you're
going to see so many captures you're
going to be confused until the final
move so let you look at this for awhile
this is really cool it's White's turn to
move and we're going to see 1001
consecutive captures after which they
let the dogs out right who let the dogs
out yeah ok
and courts should know I had figured out
95 was impossible on the other hand it's
hard to suggest to move because the
Knights attacked and pinned 95 seems to
solve all of his problems and if we
trade all the pieces off it'll be a draw
because the pawn structure is the same
but White has a trick at the end trades
Queens takes on e6 now the Knights
hanging so nine takes b2 takes on c8 so
black has to take on d1 and now the
trickiest move you ever saw
what can last answer wait is it the
trickiest what move should yeah that's
right 9c six BAM I hate when that
happens
and out of nowhere all of black's pieces
are attacked white's threatening Knight
takes rook Knight takes bishop and this
Knights attacked just in case for later
right the most obvious of is rook takes
Bishop allowing the winning Knight fork
okay on the other hand it's hard to
suggest another move for black it's a
tough position yeah it's rough I tells
you and in 1970 by teenage eagles
already like and not funny right 1970
wasn't funny yet yeah okay and black did
what Martin very good okay he knows his
yeah so this is completely equal
material but blacks going to lose all of
his pieces well one of them okay that
was a nice game that was in an Olympiad
or a European team championship same
thing no totally different totally
different okay and this was in
baden-baden so the game was pretty
botton right not so good okay so of
course should I play Knight f3 you may
have noticed course please play d4 efore
Knight f3 g3 he can't make up his mind
nine c3 can make up his mind okay course
noise white boring loves boring now it's
a benoni hi tricked you okay now
suddenly Joe garni is interest
he's like it's a benoni he's like what
he wants to know the theory from 1981
alright whatever yeah alright and Jo
Kang Jae's like why I had this position
before right yeah okay 986 don't play
that do you okay h3 put it in H Bishop
f4 attacking the D pawn rook e8 black
ignores it because it's a Benoni always
playing crazy the Benoni
9 - d - why doesn't take kazoo Benoni
okay now black plays the best move ever
bishop f8 always play Bishop f8 e for
now this maneuver course no he does very
important 92 94 your dream of the
Pannonia to play 9 c4 then play 9 c4
again I don't know how you can do it ok
white as the center White has better
development White has the weak D pawn to
attack black has nothing black resigned
on strategical reasons alone no okay
black play b5 now Joel eggs black yeah
he's like b5 finally yeah that's a black
wants to play now the game is very
complicated a good idea against course a
1980 riot rook e1 c4 not a good move
because it's that a for following my
rule always play a 4 right
9 c 5 takes 93 Joe still likes black he
got the 9 to d3 right and so now that
night on d3 is the greatest night ever
tax this this and this the only thing to
do is to ignore them all that's the only
thing to do ok and as you have pointed
out the blunder which was not played you
could do to check me you don't see no
I'm kidding 9 takes e4 ok and the guys
like thanks for the rook and course
plays like thanks for all your pawns so
white has a knight and two pawns for a
rook in when I taught the beginner class
which was not recorded lucky for you the
people at home
I explained the pieces have a value
but not the exact value of the book tell
zero the book will tell you a night and
two pawns is equal to a ruck but I don't
know these rooks look so good here I
would have I'd rather have all these
minor pieces to this rook in the corner
defending upon terrible now d6 is
attacked so he defended it queen f1
defending his knight on c4 because the
goal is to play Knight c49 h5 attacking
the bishop their ship retreats Bishop g7
finally rook takes a seven double X clam
when your opponent plays that and you
missed it psychologically crushing it
looks like black has sufficient defense
a queen in aruch but as in chess in real
life never walk into a fork okay and
that's exactly what happened black
played rook takes rook and white played
the obvious move pawn to b6
I think when that happens okay so if
black had seen rook takes a 7 probably
still couldn't stop - what you gonna do
okay yeah terrible okay and passed pawn
the seventh rank pretty solid e5e5e5 and
Black has a nice night on h5 terrible I
like White's Knights now Bishop takes
Knight takes pawn takes Queen a6
threatening a 8 equals Queen if you were
in my beginner class you would know that
y can get two queens that you would know
I could get nine Queens because we
discussed it okay now who wants to try
to prevent a 8 equals Queen the answer
is not the guy who had black he didn't
want to try to stop it Julian
rook hey hey okay so helping helping me
explain why that's bad
d6 attacking the rook attacking the
Queen yeah
Queen D it's as good as any good move
okay now remember when I sacrificed my e
pawn confusing the class now when I play
d6 my bishop unconfuse 'as the class
yeah now be honest not good for black
like a queen on a I'll take your rook
and then oh yeah oh yeah
very suspicious answer yeah there's a
pawn on d5 yeah that answer is not so
good anyway blacks and make any of those
moves black did his usual resign right
because he's like man that eight pawn is
pretty strong I don't like that so 9 h5
didn't work out very well because it
just sat on h5 now the saying you've all
heard knight on the rim is dim okay but
I like to say Knight on the rim better
for him better for the other guy
okay so course I was getting battery
started to play well 1980 okay now he
played Yusupov my favorite player
because the Germans when they spell his
name in chess base they give him all
kinds of crazy letters like hundred
letters long okay in English why us you
POV in Russian
give me the Cyrillic no okay but in in
German there's J's and w's and lots of
s's and use there it's awesome okay also
if you want to do a chess based search
for coronary
you better not spot the way you want to
spell it because then you won't find any
games now I just put Kol are usually
that finds all the cores if I spell of
course so the way I want to spell it the
Germans don't like that the German spell
it Kor TS
hno J alright so maybe that's why he
doesn't live in new in Germany he would
know who he was
that's me yeah he's like who's that guy
alright so he's playing Yusupov who does
live in Germany uh-huh okay use of pot
punish me once we were playing soccer
and I was the goalie okay needless to
say the other team scored hundreds of
goals anyway they don't call score 24
nothing they scored a lot anyway Yusupov
kick the ball as hard as possible I
think it mathematically not possible
kick it harder hit me in the leg and
bounced off everybody around the world
heard it I fell down there was a mark on
my leg for a week and I complain to him
20 years later after we drew it's a
member when you did that he's like yeah
alright yes I'll do it again
you supplies nicknamed the tank true
story okay and to prove he was the tank
he was in his apartment of Moscow and
robbers came in and demanded money he
refused true story
they shot him twice and he's like that's
all you got if he said that but anyway
he recovered and plays chess again yeah
not only twice yeah so yusupov's tough
okay but not this game all right
so corn should I used to pause they
played this line that Yusupov plays a
lot but he better look at his book again
because didn't do so well this is a very
common line in the English and nowadays
White's playing d4 before Knight f3 'if
I've not the most common white made a
strange movie ER Bishop to d3 okay in
front of his Center upon and the game
got strange very quickly okay and then
unfortunately for Yusupov it got
tactical and then he resigned tough
losing all your pieces okay so his
Queens attacked and he moved it Queenie
6d v attacking the Queen again Queen
moved away Bishop takes Queen takes
takes now you may have noticed this
Queen is attacking this bishop and this
pawn is attacking this pawn you might
say wait a minute
is yousef of the world's worst player
what's he doing he's losing everything I
have a Yusupov saw trick he played his
trick Knight takes Queen takes e4 haha
he tricked question Oy so now the ninth
attacked the Knights defending the
bishop so if the knight moves away take
the bishop okay
Yousuf wat was not happy when course
they made his next move
and I think here he was like yeah I'll
draw this solid a solid draw yeah but
then white need to move and black didn't
win a piece so he was a piece down and
Julian's like what cuz you can raise
your hand who queen d5 I hate when that
happens
notice white is attacking blacks Queen
if black moves his Queen away the bishop
is defended
so my knight can move anywhere if he
takes them pawn takes and both Knights
are attacked again the key point is this
Bishop is no longer under attack it was
in this position the knight couldn't
move away now that I can move anywhere
Queen d5 is really strong it attacks the
Queen defends the bishop and if we trade
now both Knights are attacked although
you may have noticed White has a bishop
and black does not that's I mean I'm
sure black going to snap that's really
good because Queen d5 is a retreat I
wish Matt Larsen was you instead of
being lazy terrible I didn't have a
lesson with him yesterday in today be
still lazy okay
Queen d5 Queen g6 as recommended by you
Knight h4 Martin none of what a black do
very good Razak
now blacks down a piece that's not good
if you're taking notes down a piece not
good white has two pieces black has one
now some of you are confused but you are
confused before you came here so don't
blame me okay right Martin yeah he's
like I don't know I'm confused
alright good excuse so when grandmasters
are down two pawns or a bishop or a rock
usually they resign
fine because they're going to lose a
hundred percent of the time when you're
playing your friends for example I'm
playing Kokomo now you know down a
bishop I'm no still good one every time
so as as we've shown through practice
okay so when you're playing your friend
down a piece that means very little
for example Julian how much were you
down against Preston what and what was
the result
alright so at your level resigning might
not be the best idea okay but it's a
super grand master level they hate being
down a piece especially the
psychological destruction when they
thought it was fine an opponent played a
retreating move winning the game that's
a very nice move so partially improved
over the decades good job I played
Yusupov once I offered a draw he put his
head down for 15 minutes and accepted
then I got a GM norm solid that's their
you know my leg you know hurting me okay
way after and what would Kokomo say
about when the soccer ball hit me the
hurt soccer ball is in effect okay last
but not least this game was played in
2000 at the Olympia in Istanbul whether
it was in Europe or Asia we'll never
know
okay should we know where the Bosphorus
is now you got nothing over there you
got a little all right good job
okay so Cornish noise white and he
played d4 what a plays d4 okay now he's
six who thinks course should I play d4
going into the French defense as usual
the class is all correct
efore all right now they didn't raise
their hand no no I know you did light
though all right d5 and as all of you in
the class know Korchnoi was one of the
main exponents of the French defense for
most of his career only about 35 years
that's not most of his career is it like
half of his career okay so he played the
advanced variation to advanced for this
class and he pled the line with a 3 and
B 4 okay course sure was now you know he
was playing the Olympiad he's playing in
a team event
his teammates went up to him and said
dude we're not playing checkers over
here
okay so you started playing better at
this point okay and the opening is
boring as most openings are 95 is a
common idea you can't take it because
your bishop is hanging yeah well yeah
but you don't okay rook c1 all right now
the game gets interesting White has all
of his pieces out and he's Castle black
didn't castle yet before black castles
we have to punish him okay he's already
in Istanbul so halfway done
all right now he must've seen one of
those terrible movies that's filmed in
Istanbul well taken two three four there
was another one too okay so now course
nine goes on the attack
rar 92 attacking the rook I wouldn't lie
to you okay
black we treated the rook rook takes d4
being too dangerous why I don't know
probably Knight be five wins okay yeah
bye didn't see that 9 B 3 B six stopping
Knight c5 and he still played it now b5
attacking the Queen Bishop takes b5
night takes b5 now White's threatening
rook c8 in case of Queen takes Knight
and white would win therefore black
played rook takes rook very good
96 check which is called a Ken West
what's that called
who now that would be an eagle song ya
know desperado is slightly different
slightly Ken West your answer is better
than mine so we'll go on now
that's called as mission Zhuge as you
pointed out right in between move 9
check and now after you take it
Queen takes rook black doesn't have time
to castle because blacks Bishop is
hanging if instead white had played
Queen takes rook for example
then we could take this and if you play
check we just block and say you got
nothing and now speaking of having
nothing all but White's pieces are
hanging okay
so white played 96 check which is better
now black has to save his bishop plays
Bishop b8 defending the diagonal
terrible now on the other hand if we
play Bishop e7 Queen c6 check is
annoying man is it annoying for example
this would be better for white yeah
terrible for black okay so Bishop b8
Queen c6 check anyway the bishops 97 so
King e7 and now what did white do wait
somebody said the right move what you
said the right move you sure
I don't know how do I know on the future
okay so as somebody pointed out Bishop
a3 check would be good so white played
Rick c1 tricked you all alright rook c1
rook da and now a for the reason you
don't play a four right away is black
plays rook c8 and when you check I go
here and now you cry
well now Queen d5 and you lose the game
yeah
okay so rook see one stop encounter play
and now a for threatening Bishop a3
check man that's tough it's tough I
tells you f6 why is that bad ken west
never move f6 now you change little
little and put you together to the yeah
but okay alright f6 Bishop a3 check
let's see mm then Simon what did what
did black play here
I try to give an easy one see that's
it's all about the Benjamins all right
and somebody said the right move earlier
nights e5x clam now
pawn takes Knight is risky because you
lose your Queen Queen see it if you play
Queen a5 then night what well then yeah
e6 and b7
okay yeah and now my favorite move of
the game my favorite move of the lecture
because it's the last move of the
lecture oh you're right oh you're not
wow you're wrong you're the worst oh you
were so close but Julie already said
that yes 97 BAM now all the blacks
pieces are attacked I hate when that
happens
because the Queen and rook make a
battery so White's threatening those and
White's threatening this and if black
plays the obvious move Queen takes Queen
then Knight takes da check BAM hate when
that happens
yeah but you hung your knight 97 and
only Martin knows what black did yeah
yeah that's right
now he didn't do that he resigned yeah
and that was a good game as in Olympiad
so you got a win for your team okay
although Sebastian Fowler took it too
far okay that was a good jog if you got
it otherwise not good cheated now you
did tell her he was a cheating feller
yeah true story all right now to be
serious it's the last two I'll be
serious during this lecture yesterday we
have bad news in the chess world former
world champions mother Vishy Anand his
mom died yesterday 79 I think something
like that died in her sleep so that's
unfortunate we're going to see this she
here for the Sinquefield Cup so we'll
have to wish him well and hope that he
continues to play great chests
I'm good friends with issue so I was sad
to hear of his mom's passing my dad
passed last year and so I'll get to see
my funny lectures so terrible what not
funny little funny
how old is Vichy and on I know the
answer to that since we're the same age
hold on a minute hold on I carry the one
was tax wait Ken watch that's more than
69 how old am i he's carrying he's
carrying the one too I will be I'm 45
as his own on he'll be 46 in December
and as this unit has said to me many
times when watching my videos class
dismissed
doesn't want watch that